[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
good morning
depending on where you are in the
country
noon eastern
11th central
nine pacific
whether you're having breakfast or lunch
we're gonna go through the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends today
we're gonna round up the [ __ ] list
for sure
yesterday was a very
excuse me yesterday was a very very busy
day on the show you know we had rachel
bitkoffer here
we also
we also had we had the former guy show
up i don't know if you guys caught that
if you didn't you can go over to the
youtube channel and you can you can
catch the clip of the former guy showing
up on the tony michaels podcast
to explain
him inciting violence over the weekend
which i i believe we need to talk about
today uh look look at all the oh man
morning y'all
says yoda
caitlin's here
uh who else is here what else we got we
got all kinds of uh robin's here hello
robin
mj lots of [ __ ] to round up you goddamn
right we're gonna round up the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends today
apparently tom brady is retiring in the
entire country think that's the most
important [ __ ] thing that's happening
uh if if you're if you're paying
attention to tom brady and you think
that's the most important thing ever
you're doing it wrong i'm not saying you
shouldn't you know like yeah he's
retiring or oh he's retiring
but it is not the most important story
in this country today
it's not we're gonna explain that here
on the tony michaels podcast mj says i
love the [ __ ] i'm army
mj you i think you came up with that
that phrase hey robin how are you
everyone's here today you guys ready to
round up the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends are you ready are you
ready because we didn't we didn't do a
lot of [ __ ] list roundup yesterday um
because we were so busy with the show we
had a great show yesterday
we again we had rachel bitkoffer on of
strike pack the political strategist she
was talking about strategic outrage and
how the hell we're gonna use
uh this nazi rally [ __ ]
this fascism to win in 2022 we can do it
we can do it we just have to stay pissed
we just have to go [ __ ] vote
we can do it but we got us we have got
to have strategic outrage and she came
on yesterday and gave us a little
insight into that and then speaking of
outrage we
we we might have had we might have had a
parody of the former guy on yesterday
you guys know john walsh he does a trump
impersonation he came on yesterday's
trump it was [ __ ] hilarious again go
subscribe to the youtube channel you can
see that
uh video over there i cut that out and
put that on the youtube channel
alone so you go see it you can also
watch the interview with rachel
that we did yesterday the conversation
that we had yesterday
and then we did a great interview with
missy modell
missy's fantastic she does great
parodies uh looking forward to some of
the videos that she's gonna be releasing
in the coming days and we'll probably be
playing them here on the podcast
and i'll be retweeting them uh as well
so you'll be looking be looking and go
follow missy
i'll probably re-air the missy interview
this weekend
that way you guys have the interview on
youtube and you can watch that interview
alone it's really fun we had a lot of
fun with missy she's welcome back
anytime
was happy to have her
uh we recorded that a while ago and and
we were able to air it yesterday we have
a very very
very significant and very interview
coming up that we have recorded
um it has to do with january 6. it has
to do with the insurrectionist um you
guys are gonna want to pay attention
over the next few days of this interview
that we're going to be dropping
and i can't say much more than that but
you need to pay attention
so um be watching the twitter feed
be watching what's happening um because
i would imagine we're going to have
clips of this thing
either tomorrow thursday and then the
interview will drop sometime in the next
two or three days it's huge
huge stuff huge news huge news
speaking of the news everyone thinks
tom brady
is so important
well i'll i'll give you that he might be
a good football player but he's no
he is he is no carter g woodson let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we're gonna go through
the tweety tweets and attorney trends
today
uh we're gonna we're gonna get we're
gonna get to it here
uh we we didn't go through the the [ __ ]
list roundup a lot yesterday because we
were so busy
uh holy [ __ ] we might have to go to
three hours a day
i mean you know that we got so much [ __ ]
to cover so much [ __ ] to do and then we
gotta go through the tweety tweets and
trendy trends how are we gonna find time
in two hours i never thought with doing
two hours a day we we wouldn't be able
to find time but it might it may work
out that way i don't know i don't know
we'll see we'll see what happens again
tune in because we got a a big interview
coming up you definitely do not want to
miss that
um there's a lot a lot of so let's go a
lot of nazi [ __ ] going on a lot of nazi
[ __ ] going on
you can see uh eugene here uh he posted
most americans are tired
of all this racist crap republican
leadership is making a bad bet this will
cost him dearly hashtag racists are not
okay
look at this [ __ ]
you see this look at this
look at this let's go brandon
you can see the people behind there
howling hitler
with uh what what is this on that sign
what is that what what is i guess let's
go brandon is a nazi phrase now
i it seems nazi to me the nazis seem to
like it they really seem to like it
um i wouldn't i wouldn't dare if if you
were somebody to you know this looks
like a phone number here
i'm just saying
that should have been censored i i
oh
thank you gene for your tweet as always
um
so everyone's you know really worried
about tom brady in his retirement
whether you like him love him hate him
whatever
and people are really concerned about
his retirement what what what the hell
is going on here come on
come on let's get get get the tweet
there we go okay
now now we're back to normal
so a lot of people are concerned about
tom brady's retirement well you know
fine whatever that's cool that's cool if
you want to be worried about it but
there's a lot of [ __ ] happening in the
world right tom brady was going to
retire regardless
regardless he was going to retire yeah
he might be one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time some might say
he is the best the goat
but um i remember i remember the guy had
a maga hat in his locker do you remember
that do you remember the guy had a maga
hat
palled around with trump you remember
that hmm
okay uh scott says happening now court
hearing in high profile january 6 case
richard biggo barnett who's accused of
putting his feet on on the desk of the
office suite of nancy pelosi and
stealing mail from her office
barnett begins to tell by telling judge
he's growing his beard out until all the
january sixers are free oh well
you know that has legal standing i'm
sure the judge will buy that garbage
um
also scott reports per prosecutor plea
deal
all right excuse me plea talks
a pair
appear taught have
to have stalled
sorry scott you can
your your misspelling confused me no big
deal i'm not a grammar nazi feds are
suggesting the court set a trial date
um so this is this is pretty significant
um and this comes after the weekend i
wonder if this has anything with trump
saying he's gonna pardon people i wonder
if this has anything to do with it that
this guy's saying until all the j sixers
are free
[ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this guy let him go
to trial that's what i say you know what
happens when you go to trial and you
lose a try at trial when you're
sentencing good [ __ ] them okay let's see
you know
a lot of these low-level um january
sixers that have already taken plea
deals
they were some of the smartest
[ __ ] that got caught up in this
they got caught up in the heat they went
busted windows smeared their [ __ ] on the
wall and then they walked away with
probation or a couple months in prison
maybe even a couple years
well that is not gonna keep happening
these judges are not gonna put up with
that [ __ ]
uh let's see here we have david perdue
uh this video ron posted this video
trump endorsed david perdue of course
he's trump endorsed that's why he lost
in his senate race
kicked off his stop stacy tour
and his campaign for georgia governor
today by
pledging to create a quote-unquote
special election fraud police force they
want storm troopers to take away your
vote
i'm requiring audits after elections
listen to this [ __ ] this is the fascist
plan and everyone's worried about tom
brady
listen to what this [ __ ] says
it's high time that we take care of
voting integrity in this state we've had
laws forever i don't believe they've
ever been you [ __ ] have been
the ones in charge of election integrity
forever you [ __ ] are the ones
who had the reigns of government in
georgia to change election laws and been
doing it what the [ __ ] are you talking
about of course the way they should have
been so what i'm proposing
is a law enforcement division an
election law enforcement division
election law enforcement division
what laws are you going to enforce
enforce david perdue if the laws aren't
working if there's no such thing as
election integrity in georgia what the
[ __ ] are you going to enforce
if not the laws that are already in
place this is all [ __ ] nonsense just
[ __ ] drivel
it's we're going to steal your vote oh
you don't want you want to vote blue in
georgia you want to make georgia blue
well guess what we're going to do we're
going to steal your [ __ ] vote from
you
this is fascism knocking on the door
folks and everyone's worried about tom
brady not playing football get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
listen to me listen to me and listen
[ __ ] good
there will be no nfl if these fascists
take over
there will be no nfl
there won't be an mba there won't be the
restaurant down the street your school
won't exist
they want to destroy the entire country
do you understand
they don't want elections
they don't want government that's not
what they want
they want a fascist state
and they're hell bent on doing it
david perdue is standing here saying and
he's gonna finish saying i've watched
this clip already this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
that if the election doesn't go my way
they can't announce that i lost
they know they're gonna [ __ ] lose
they know we're pissed and we have to
stay pissed
and worrying about whether tom brady's
going to play for patriots or buccaneers
or whoever the [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] rat's ass about that
manga piece of [ __ ] playing football no
one gives a [ __ ] you want are you
concerned about your who's playing in
the super bowl are you concerned about
it there won't be a super bowl
think about that for a second
think about what's at stake here
everyone is so [ __ ] so [ __ ]
comfortable with their cushy little
lives
their restaurants their schools their
communities their churches
their tv their reality tv shows
their sports teams
their college sports teams that won't
exist
you're not understanding what's at stake
you don't get it
they don't give a [ __ ] what you want
david perdue is standing here saying we
don't care if you vote we don't care if
you vote and we don't care who you vote
for
we're going to create stormtroopers so
that way we can make the election the
way we want it listen inside the georgia
bureau of investigation and also an
audit process that before a statewide
election can be confirmed or
it has to be audited by an independent
outside third party entity
we want to make sure that the results
that we report and the state certifies
are the results that we want not what
the voters want it's what he's saying so
what he's saying
he wants to check for bamboo ballots
before the ballots are counted
if you're not paying attention if you're
not listening this is what they want
this is what he's saying this is a
trump-backed candidate
who lost in the runoff because of it
and i believe he'll lose in this race as
long as we stay pissed and go [ __ ]
vote and have some strategic [ __ ]
outrage about what this motherfucker's
talking about
tom brady's retiring
okay sure fine good now on to the next
thing that [ __ ] matters
just like you do in business when you
file a financial report you have to have
an auditing firm come in and verify that
you did that report against certain
standards
fascism fascism fascism
we don't want your vote to count
especially if the vote that you make
is not the one that we want joe says uh
yeah [ __ ] this you goddamn right [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] perdue [ __ ] the gqp [ __ ] the
goddamn let's go brandon nazis that's
what they are the let's go brandon nazis
want to take your elections she also
says audited by an independent outside
third party in it yeah sure david we'll
get right on that
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
election storm troopers that's what they
want okay yeah you got it
cyber cyber ninjas
okay yep
been there done that [ __ ] okay let's
move on
uh there's more nazis it's just nazis
are [ __ ] everywhere
you don't believe me
oh well
the the former president united states
is so goddamn desperate because
everyone's finding out that that
[ __ ] was tearing up [ __ ]
documents that proves that he committed
treason
that's right it looks like there's
documents that proves that he was trying
to commit treason
go look up the [ __ ] word treason
overthrow the government he said
overturn but he means overthrow
overthrow is the word
they tried to overthrow our constitution
in the united states
and if you remember back if you rewind
the clock and you remember back to
december
of 2020 with the big lie and the ramping
and the rabble rousing of january 6
because donald trump knew that he wasn't
going to win
he knew that he'd lost
he [ __ ] knew they all [ __ ] knew
that's why they were trying to rig the
game that's why they were trying to
overthrow the government of the united
states of america
that's why he's so pissed off at mike
pence and they [ __ ] hate mike pence
because he wasn't willing to overthrow
the government because it's terri zun
got it
so he stands on stage this weekend
to make sure to have his rally cry
of go commit violence for me he's not
going to win an election
he's not they're not
they know it
they know democracy is the mortal enemy
of fascism they know it that's why they
want to tear it apart
it's the weapon that we have with the
ballot
and we have to crawl over [ __ ] hot
lava to use our ballot
against fascism
it is a must we have to
you want you wanna you wanna you wanna
discuss who's retiring football you
wanna [ __ ] worry about who's gonna
play in the super bowl
if that's the [ __ ] you wanna worry about
you better start worrying about the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] matters
and david perdue down in [ __ ] georgia
talking about how he's gonna have a
storms trooper election crew that's
gonna go in and bang up the results that
they want if they don't get the votes
that's what you need to be paying
attention to
look at this look at this meme everyone
i'm gonna this this is in the feed i'm
gonna retweet this again here
top of the feed
oh god damn what the hell
it's not retweeting what the hell's
happening what is happening
it won't retweet i don't know what the
hell we'll get to it
copy and paste this
this is super important spread this [ __ ]
around like it's herpes
voted democrat voted republican better
start giving a [ __ ]
america better start giving a [ __ ] and
they better start giving a [ __ ] quick
really [ __ ] fast
the nazis are at the front door the
fascists are ready to go
why is this not doing what i wanted to
do i said most americans know the
definition of treason
most most of them there are some that do
not oh oh you want the definition of
treason how about overthrow the
government
he said it in his [ __ ] statement and
let's be clear the reason why the reason
why donald trump is standing on stage
where is that [ __ ] me
what the hell
oh it's here somewheres it's gotta be
underneath here somewhere
maybe it's uh
oh maybe it's here
no
there it is
retweeted it now it's at the top of the
timeline
most americans know the definition of
treason most donald trump definitely
does not understand the definition of
treason because he admitted to it yeah
we wanted to overturn the election you
mean overthrow overthrow the election
overthrow the government
with violence that's what he did on
january sixth he knew the only way that
he can remain president on january 6 if
he could rabble arouse his people to go
commit violence to make sure that he was
the dictator the king
their orange mussolini jesus
he's doing it again
it's it's the big lie all over again
we're we're back in december 2020 with
this [ __ ]
he's standing on stage telling his
people go commit violence in my name and
i will pardon you that's what he did on
january 6th we're going to find that out
you've seen stuart rhodes was and 10
others of the oath keepers
they've been charged with conspiracy of
sedition
okay that's one step away from treason
in a conspiracy
you think they just came up with that
all by their selves
we seen the reporting from rolling
stones months ago
about members of congress possibly
pimping out pardons from the president
at the time donald trump that yeah just
come here and [ __ ]
bang up the government overthrow the
government and i'll pardon you
he didn't pardon [ __ ] one of them not
one of them now he's promising on stage
he's gonna pardon him again that's what
this is he's trying to get them to save
him so he can be president or king or
whatever the [ __ ]
whatever the hell he thinks he's going
to do
all right let's uh let's move on here
let's see
i'm way far in this thing where where am
i at all right there we go
uh rachel rachel brings up a good point
here um i don't know what the [ __ ] that
this garrett for michigan who is this
guy who is it did anybody know who this
[ __ ] guy is
i mean he's definitely a candidate for
maybe the most punchable face on the
internet today
listen to what this [ __ ] says there's a
lot of situations out there um yeah talk
about rape and everything else and hey
maybe they deserve an abortion
not really that many situations out
there you you
garrett you [ __ ] not that many
situations rapists rape you dumb
[ __ ] what are you talking about
yeah you know there's there's rape and
there's rape like get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] for life and i have
a great personal story of one of my
mentors and he was going through life oh
he his mentor he you know you know
what what
what the [ __ ] don't these [ __ ] ball
sacks get why why do you who do not have
a [ __ ] uterus get to tell women what
the [ __ ] to do with their bodies why why
don't you [ __ ] get it why they're
tired of listening to you [ __ ] nut
sex talking about abortion and talking
about their [ __ ] uteruses what don't
you [ __ ] understand he was adopted so
he started to look up his birth family
oh to figure out who they were and he
figured out that his mom was being raped
in a subway um train station by five
guys oh my gosh and it well well get
make him a [ __ ] hero then
what the [ __ ] are you what is the point
here garrett what's the point get to the
point tell us how you hate [ __ ] women
get to it kind of like tore out his
heart when he found that out but then he
started to really appreciate and
understand i love how this is this guy's
personal story
this is this is this guy this white ball
sack here this is this guy's [ __ ]
personal story about abortion some guy
he knows
some guy he knows has a story get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] you know
what you should do you know what you
should do if you want to have an opinion
on abortion refer to a woman
someone with a [ __ ] uterus how about
that how about you defer to them you
[ __ ] idiot what his birth mother went
through that she had the courage
to deliver him
and since then since he was delivered he
has helped thousands of people be better
versions of themselves and so what we
must start to focus on is not only to
defend the dna when it's created oh [ __ ]
see here we go defend the dna see this
[ __ ]
see see they don't believe in science
but here they are defending the dna get
the [ __ ] out of here
but however how about we start inspiring
women in the culture to let them
understand and know how heroic they are
how about how about you let them just
decide their own [ __ ] health choices
how about that i think that's what women
want women don't want to be [ __ ]
heroes they just want to decide their
own [ __ ] health care right
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
garrett
stupid [ __ ] and how unbelievable they
are that god put them in this moment and
they don't know that little baby inside
them may be the next president maybe the
next person that changes um humanity may
get us out of the situation maybe in the
future we don't know that is what we
must do is start to create yeah you
don't know that either you don't know
that either so stay the [ __ ] out of her
goddamn liberty would you please
stay the [ __ ] out of other people's
[ __ ] liberty it's enough of this [ __ ]
it's completely enough of this [ __ ] this
is the whole oh well i've got a story
i'm a man and i've got a story from
another man that proves why i i should
be able to make decisions for women
create that culture and there's already
a culture for that catholic charities is
a great one that they help these moms go
through
and deliver and give these kids up for
adoption i have lots of friends who have
adopted kids because they can't have
children naturally and so we must always
always protect that dna and allow it to
have a voice
so now it's it's not babies it's not
they're not pro dna and they're not
pro-life anymore they're pro-dna
here they are rachel says gop to
pregnant rape victims god put you in
this moment the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
how about you just how how about how
about you [ __ ] sweaty white nut sacks
just step aside and women can make their
own decisions of their bodies people
with uteruses can make decisions about
their uterus and about their dna dumb
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] i'm
pissed off this morning have you noticed
i'm [ __ ] pissed i'm [ __ ] pissed
that everyone's concerned that tom
brady's retiring and nazis are down in
florida saying let's go brandon
okay
some of our favorites mayo says most
americans know donald trump is a traitor
and a terrorist
yeah i think i think most americans
understand that the problem is most
americans aren't paying attention to the
right [ __ ] you you can be upset you can
be excited that tom brady's retiring i'm
not saying that you can have those
feelings that's cool and all but listen
you won't be discussing who's retiring
from what
if you let the fascist come in the back
door we have to open the front door and
confront them now right now
they are on the front doorstep
they're there they're waiting they're
ready to take over
they ain't [ __ ] around
they're [ __ ] flying swastikas and
let's go brandon signs down in orlando
and the governor's like oh nazis what
nazis i don't see any nazis
they they look like trump supporters to
me let's go brandon
well you doubting me
go look go see what statements the
governor of florida gave yesterday about
the nazi rally that happened in his
state
with the phrase that he loves for his
crowds to chant
why would the governor of the state of
florida disparage a bunch of [ __ ]
nazis
chanting the phrase that he loves
the nazi phrase let's go brandon why
would he do that
he wouldn't do that he loves let's go
brandon he loves the let's go brandon
nazis
he wouldn't disparage them
you wait
eight off a good
wrong click
most americans adolf twittler slayer
says most americans don't want an
authoritarian
dictator like the former guy yeah no
[ __ ]
i agree 100
but it ain't gonna matter what most
americans want
it's about what most americans will do
what will you do
chris maloney here tweets the creep of
fascism is real and it is that's what
i'm talking about
that's what i'm saying it's where it's
at
uh molly post this craziness where
republicans try to install pro-trump
secretaries of state is really scary all
told some 21 candidates who dispute mr
biden's victory are running for
secretary of state in 18 states are you
paying attention it's not just the
senate it's not just the congress
they're they're they're wanting to come
if you do not open the front door to
fascism and we do not confront them
and hit this head-on and fight this
head-on because democracy in the ballot
is the tool to beat fascism it is
that's why they want to destroy
democracy because it is the mortal enemy
of fascism
in 18 states there's 21 candidates that
that think
that
spread the [ __ ] lie that biden lost
still
we're over 400 days past this [ __ ]
according to united states action a
non-partisan group tracking races for
secretary of state throughout the
country
21 candidates and 18 states
the threat is real
you have david perdue and georgia saying
oh oh if you don't vote the way we want
you to vote well we'll just have we'll
just have a police force
to make sure that we get the result that
we want before we announce
this is big lie planning 101 what they
want to do is hold the [ __ ] vote they
want to hold the vote so they can spread
the big lie around let's go to the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends this
is really [ __ ] pissing me off today
today is february 1st
it's the first day of black history
month and there's a lot of history even
built into that history there alone
today is the anniversary of the signing
of the 13th amendment the abolition of
slavery in this country
and tom brady's trending at number two
you see why i'm [ __ ] pissed
you see why i'm [ __ ] pissed off
[ __ ] tom brady
[ __ ] him you want you want to again
do you want to order pizza during the
super bowl do you want to have to make
the decision what cheese dip do we
[ __ ] make for the super bowl party
do we invite these friends you know
they're kind of obnoxious when they get
drunk
do we want to hang out with our family
this this super bowl they're kind of
wacky they got the q and on stuff going
on
that is not decisions that you will be
making
you will not be thinking about who is
playing in the super bowl you not be
worried about what time the super bowl
is on how long it's gonna last who
houses you're gonna go to are you gonna
go to a restaurant and watch it
what type of pizza are you gonna order
you won't be making those decisions
you don't get to have that with fascism
they decide what you get to have
they're saying it out loud
david perdue is saying if you don't
produce the election results we want
we'll overturn them with a stormtrooper
police type state
ron desantis can't even come out in the
open and say yeah the let's go brandon
nazis
i don't like them can't even [ __ ]
muster up the courage to do that
donald trump standing on stage over the
weekend inciting violence making sure
that his
his supporters understand that they may
have to use violence and he'll have to
pardon him once he becomes in power
because he definitely wants to overthrow
the government of the united states i
mean hell that's what he was trying to
do on january 6 he [ __ ] said it in
his statement
and we're finding out more and more
about the documents that are related to
the january 6
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt
people
ripping up documents hmm
i wonder what someone is scared of
tom brady's retiring
jesus christ
good put that [ __ ] out the
pasture okay let's go on
here's bigger news than tom brady you
want another story this bigger news at
least seven historical black colleges in
the university reported bomb threats on
tuesday
at least one of them howard university
has also received a bomb threat monday
oh tony there's no such thing as let's
go brandon nazis
there's a group
in this country
they're a violent nazi set of [ __ ]
white pieces of [ __ ]
fascist
they love they love [ __ ] hitler
and they're they're definitely pissed
off that hitler didn't succeed
their name is adam waffen and adam
waffen is hell-bent on and creating
violence
the type of violence that donald trump
was inciting
over the weekend
and saying out loud hey let's go brandon
nazis if you commit violence in my name
and make sure that i'm in power because
i definitely want to overthrow the
government because we tried to do it
we tried to do it that's what we were
trying to do and all the people who
helped me i'll pardon them and i'll
pardon you
don't worry why do you think this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] barnett with his feet up on
nancy pelosi's desk is not gonna take a
plea deal
huh
and they're calling in bomb threats
to hbcus
over and over and over again
it's to stoke fear
that's what they want they want us to be
afraid are you afraid i'm not [ __ ]
afraid
i'm i'm ready to stay pissed and go
[ __ ] vote i'm ready for some
strategic [ __ ] outrage
about a bunch of let's go brandon nazis
calling him bomb threats
you [ __ ] weak pieces of [ __ ]
why don't you go open a [ __ ] book and
read
maybe maybe that'll make you a little
[ __ ] stronger what does christopher
have to say here bomb threats at nine
hbcus on the first day of black history
month is where we're at in this country
yes
you want to rally cry there it is the
first day of black history month
the anniversary of the 13th amendment
the abolition of slavery
and the nazis the let's go brandon nazis
are calling in threats to hbcus hmm
wonder if they have anything to do with
each other
i don't know if you know this but on
january 6
they wanted a race war they wanted
violence to break out
they wanted black lives matter there
they wanted antifa there that's why they
keep saying this [ __ ] that they were
there i was them
because that's what they wanted
what do you think the whole written
house trial was about you think they
like the rittenhouse kid [ __ ] no he's
just another [ __ ] expendable piece of
[ __ ] and their little [ __ ] narrative
to take over our country
just another [ __ ] pawn in their game
the written house that kyle rittenhouse
that little [ __ ]
they wanted to use that trial to stoke
violence it's stoke war they want
violence they want to fight
we should be ready to vote
vote vote
vote
your neighbors your friends everyone
[ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote stay [ __ ] pissed stay
outraged
if you live in florida
you should be asking every day every
[ __ ] day why has ha why has ron
desantis not come out and said i'm not a
let's go brandon nazi and i don't want
anyone saying let's go brandon because
it is it is a nazi symbol now
it's a nazi it's the nazis have
appropriated it's a nazi thing now it's
nazis
the let's go brandon nazis they're
calling in bomb threats to historical
black colleges and universities on the
anniversary of the 13th amendment the
abolition of slavery
why do you think february is black
history month because every month is
black history month because black
history is american history and american
history is black history
the only reason why we celebrate
february is because it is the
anniversary of the 13th amendment
and they're calling in bomb threats
today
they're at the front door folks
they're there they're waiting
they're waiting
let's see most americans is trending
let's see it's it number
number 17
on the [ __ ] list
number 17
most americans let's see let's let's um
hell let's run down this one there's a
lot of good ones
uh we've already done a few of them here
dude joe i read this one earlier and i
you are this is
this is such a dumb this is the
stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] this is how
fascism creeps in joe
i'm i'm not exactly against you walsh
i'm not for joe walsh though [ __ ]
definitely
most americans abhor trump truth
most americans don't support aoc's
policies
[ __ ]
that is a sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] joe
if you have looked at bare bones what
aoc's policies would do for this country
the majority of the country supports her
policies you want decent [ __ ] wages
you want to make sure you can raise a
[ __ ] family
in this country
without having to be broken poor even
though you work two or three [ __ ]
jobs
you want to make sure that because you
work hard in this country
that you have a [ __ ] decent
retirement at some point do you want to
make sure that you don't go [ __ ]
completely bankrupt
because you have a medical expense
joe
get a [ __ ] life
you like the buzzword aoc i get it
you like the libtard socialist but it
doesn't work on me most americans now
identify as independents
[ __ ] i believe most of most
americans that identify as pro-democracy
i believe the movement is growing and
growing and growing
most americans are center right center
left bull [ __ ] they're not sent or
anything
they're pro democracy they want it back
and if you ask them line by line by line
they would love aoc's policies as long
as you didn't use the the letters aoc
how come there's not a political party
that represents most americans there is
there is one there's only one
unfortunately
it would be nice to have two three four
five six but we don't have that type of
government
and one of our parties in this country
are let's go brandon nazis
your tweet sucks joe
sorry this one sucks
joe's got to anyone here we go with the
review see what want to review this
before tweeting no not really but we'll
go ahead and we'll do it
your tweet sucks featured on today's
[ __ ] list roundup
yeah we want to tweet it thanks twitter
your tweet [ __ ] sucks joe pluck your
head out of your ass
this this is how fascism has creeped in
in the last 30 years [ __ ] like this
right here
lies like this
this is a lie it's a [ __ ] lie it's
gaslighting that americans don't want
aoc's policy that americans identify as
independent
that americans are center right center
left
they just they want decent [ __ ] wages
joe
they want decent wages they don't want
to go broke because of a medical bill
they want to be able to retire without
having to [ __ ] be sick and broke
they want to be able to put their kids
through [ __ ] school
from the age of three until they're
through college so their kids can
participate in the economy so their kids
can make a decent [ __ ] wage so their
kids don't go bankrupt over a medical
bill what don't you people understand
and i i think it was um someone said it
i'm gonna find it i think it was chris
there it is right here chris says it the
best
this is one of the best today most
americans don't know what most americans
are concerned about
there you go thank you chris thanks for
the tweet
tweet of the day go retweet this from
chris
how in the hell does this only have 24
retweets
okay let's go down
most americans think tom cotton is an
idiot
oh i i think you could put all in front
of this
you know all americans
i mean there might be a handful you know
a couple people
not that [ __ ] many
not that [ __ ] many people
um think that tom cotton isn't a [ __ ]
idiot
did he do
robin's laughing sorry i'm not getting
any comments i'm just i'm fired up today
um
harry says my kids are voting democrat
that's that's good they're pro
voting pro-democracy
now lisa says i said something like that
tony you tweeted something like chris
did
tweet it send it to me at dm i'll put
you on here
i try to go through the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends and we go from the
top i try i want to work you guys in if
i can let's see
oh
most americans avenge your resistor one
of our favorites here again oh come on
come on come on gone zoom there we go
most americans would agree that ted cruz
madison cawthon and the republican party
are trying to destroy our democracy
abso [ __ ] lutely
republicans destroy democracy
democrats want to deliver i want to take
a minute here to explain this to you
because this is something that
the left democrats
sometimes pro-democracy people
misunderstand
and i say it a lot in spaces right
and i don't know have you guys been
going to these twitter spaces you
probably should um there's a lot of good
conversation that happens in there
i say this a lot in spaces
i say this
what the republicans the gqp the let's
go brandon nazis have understood for
decades
is that politics and government are two
different things
they're separate they're not the same
government is not politics politics is
not government
it's not
it's not how it works
they're two different things
government
is once you take take control
of administrations and legislators then
you can legislate you can administrate
policy you can argue you can negotiate
you can compromise on policy
hell you can you can obstruct if you
want we've seen it before
the administration or legislation of
policy
but the politics is what gets you into
government
is what makes it to where you can
actually govern
republicans understand this now they use
lies misinformation fascism
complete utter [ __ ] [ __ ] and
drivel
for their politics
and they do a damn good job
a damn good job at propaganda if you
haven't noticed
lie travels around in this country
before the [ __ ] truth can even get
out of bed and put its feet on the floor
that's up to us
that's what i'm saying about tom brady
in the super bowl fine have your super
bowl have fun but understand there's a
reason why we have it
there's a reason why we have liberty in
this country
and that's what we strive for and if you
think that fascism is going to deliver
you liberty
well then you haven't looked up the
[ __ ] word liberty yet
and we have to we have to use the
politics and we have to separate it from
government
we these are two different things
they're not the same me and rachel
talked about it yesterday on the show
if you want to go watch that interview i
actually cut it up go go watch it over
on the youtube channel
and i think there's three there's three
conversations that we've had with rachel
so far i hope to have her back
every week
every single week uh robin yeah tony i
know it probably isn't trending but
there's an article about yes i seen your
article about ted cruz i retweeted it of
the supreme court uh if i which i
probably will get to it today robin
we've got two full hours of the [ __ ]
list roundup two full hours
of the [ __ ] list roundup today you know
you know now we do two hours every
single day this is the second week of
doing two hours of the tony michaels
podcast every single day noon eastern 11
central youtube twitter and twitch
and if you're not following this now and
you're not listening by now you're going
to want to listen this week
because we have a huge interview in the
can
big news
it's not just me talking to someone
it's significant
very very very significant
we talked for over an hour to this
person who knows a thing or two
about some very
very substantial charges that were
placed
on the january six insurrectionist
going to be teasing this over the next
few days and then dropping the interview
we're not sure thursday or friday yet
we're still trying to get the interview
edited
and we're trying to seek distribution
you're gonna want to watch this
it's going to be big and we'll cut it
we'll cut it in its own individual
interview too because on i think i think
our plan
so far is to air it
thursday or friday we're not sure yet
we're still working on that the schedule
because you know we do bonehead of the
week on friday
but we might have to do three hours on
friday i don't know maybe we'll do the
interview then then bone end of the week
and then we'll do the [ __ ] list roundup
you guys really like the [ __ ] list
roundup don't you
it's it's very cool okay uh robin um
let's see
i want to get to your your article here
let's do this let's do this let's go to
a quick break and then we'll be right
back and rob and i i'll i'll show your
your your ted cruz the court case and
we'll talk about that for a second uh
stay stay around we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babel maga
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
[Music]
we are back with the [ __ ] list roundup
uh robin had posted this and i think
it's gonna be some news um it hasn't it
hasn't started trending yet robin but i
i think it's going to uh sheldon
whitehouse has brought this up he
tweeted this um this was a several days
ago it's a case about ted cruz and the
supreme court or supreme court reveals
the end game for big right wing donors
now basically what they want to do is
allow a total anonymous unlimited
spending in elections
um this is another move for the fascist
they're wanting to move not not just in
your election laws
and your election boards but they're
also wanting to bang up the [ __ ]
money
that's what they're wanting to do um
i'll retweet this here i i'm not going
to read the article here
but
uh you're right this is probably very
significant
and that the makeup of our court
speaking of our court
speaking of our court um big news in the
court other than this ted cruz supreme
court case
now go read this article it's on the
hill
uh
speaking of the supreme court though
have you noticed have you noticed that
that the racist they're really [ __ ]
terrified of having a black woman
on the court
what the [ __ ] do they give a [ __ ]
what do they care
oh that's right they want a white ball
sack on the court you're so [ __ ]
pissed off you're welcome robin you're
welcome and we'll work on that story
some more as it develops okay i promise
i won't let that story go i think it's
very important
uh dem voter 20 2020 says first time
listener checking in thank you over on
twitch how is it over there on twitch
today
if you're a first time listener since we
have some first time listeners in here
we do this this show every single day
noon eastern 11 central two hours every
single day we do the [ __ ] list roundup
which we go through the tweeted tweets
and the trinity trends and then we have
great interviews great conversations
with people we even have the former guy
show up yesterday trump showed up on our
show i mean it was a parody i don't know
if you guys know john walsh i know you
guys if you guys are uh listeners here
you know who john walsh is
you know who john walsh is
he showed up as trump yesterday uh it's
[ __ ] hilarious
life on twitch ain't twitch ain't a
[ __ ] okay
okay
all right
everyone's having fun over on twitch
yesterday john wall showed up as the
parody of trump we put that uh we put
that little conversation
that we had with the former guy the
cheeto dust mobster
i got my name wrong he thought i was
tomi lauren
not tony michaels really [ __ ] it up go
watch i cut it out and put it on the
youtube channel
go on
go over there and and do that and watch
that interview also uh if you didn't
catch the interview on the second hour
yesterday with missy modell it is
fantastic missy does great parody songs
great satire
she's a fantastic musician
she's written for netflix disney others
but go watch that interview with missy
and go check out she's gonna have some
new videos dropping i believe uh this
week so
check that out as well go follow missy
on twitter she doesn't like twitter so
go [ __ ]
sorry missy go follow her on twitter
it's missy modell m-o-d-e-l-l
missy model go follow missy okay let's
see rudy giuliani is also trending
in my for you
apparently
oh
apparently
rudy giuliani uh let's see
so this former guy involved plotting the
end of the american democracy yes he was
trump ordered rui
giuliani to dude it do it
now would be a shame if the fbi had been
wiretapping rudy kaluti
and trump did not know this when he
spoke with rudy about ending democracy
uh so we'll give
we'll give tommy his due
we're going to read tristan's here
breaking donald trump ordered rudy
giuliani to push homeland security to
seize the voting machines after pushing
for military and doj to seize them
he was personally driving the process
according to the latest bombshell report
from the new york times
listen
the reason why the guy is standing on
stage
calling for his supporters the let's go
brandon nazis
the reason why he's standing on stage
calling for them to commit violence so
that he can be their dictator so he can
pardon all them
the reason why is because he's in big
[ __ ] trouble why do you think they
were trying to [ __ ] stop all these
documents
you think you think they were stopping
the documents because there wasn't
evidence of him committing seditious and
possibly treason in these
documents
that's exactly why he was trying to stop
it
i mean why do you think he doesn't want
us to see his tax returns it ain't
because of crime it's because he's
[ __ ] broke
he doesn't want us to know the truth
about him
because it's all [ __ ] it's all fraud
it's all house of cards
the whole [ __ ] and caboodle
all of it
all of it
so it is not surprising that donald
trump ordered rudy giuliani
to get homeland security which i don't
understand this right
what in the [ __ ]
what in the [ __ ] does rudy giuliani have
to do with homeland security
think about it
rudy giuliani was his personal attorney
his personal attorney
what the [ __ ] does he have to do with
homeland security seizing voting
machines well i think i know why
the dod
dod and doj wouldn't seize them
they wouldn't do it
donald trump's like hey go get those
voting machines so i can steal the
election and overthrow the government of
the united states because listen it is
our government we the people it's ours
it's not his it's not the president
united states the the the office of the
president united states it is that is
not theirs it is ours
that's what a lot of people don't
understand you know they say oh we're
not you're not a democracy we're a
republic what the [ __ ] do you think a
republic is dummy
oh we're not a buick we're a le saber
yeah right right yeah although sabre is
a type of buick
and it's also a type of automobile you
know the automobile being the government
the buick being the democracy the le
saber being the republic
how can you people how
jesus
they're waiting for jfk junior to show
up did you see some of this [ __ ] from
this trump rally
these [ __ ] weirdos
talking about how michael jackson jfk jr
and
all kinds of people who are [ __ ] dead
deader than dead dead or dead dead
deader than dead dead that are going to
come back to life
so not only is this guy going to be
president 2024 he's resurrecting dead
people
oh and the craziest part is is this dead
people that probably wouldn't even like
him
like even if he could bring jfk junior
back to life you think jfk jr would have
two [ __ ] to give to donald trump not
one [ __ ] no [ __ ] to give to donald
trump
at all
but here he is committing seditious
treason it appears if these reports are
correct or he's ordering rudy giuliani
his personal attorney who is not an
officer of the government
to commit sedition
now we haven't heard a lot from rudy
lately
other than he isn't getting paid by
donald trump
my guess is
i'm just snowballing here
that when donald trump wouldn't pay rudy
giuliani donald trump thought well i'm
not gonna pay a guy who's gonna flip on
me
just saying i'm just saying normally
normally mobsters don't pay guys that go
flip to the feds
they don't they don't normally give them
cash
uh us singer says when rudy giuliani is
the least crazy guy in the room you know
you're in the wrong room this is true
these are the reports from way back when
i don't know i'm old enough to remember
uh during the the big lie the push for
the big lie
when uh michael flynn that [ __ ]
treasonous piece of [ __ ]
michael flynn and sydney powell there's
there's another one that's wrapped up in
treason
we're in the white house pushing these
lies
pushing this [ __ ] trying to get him
to do the insurrection act of martial
law which
by the way
speaking of insurrection and martial law
that interview that we have this week
you're gonna hear that a lot in that
interview
so stay tuned for that interview it's
gonna be [ __ ] big
but in the room with michael flynn
and sydney powell those goddamn
wackadoos those q and on wackadoos
rudy giuliani seemed like the reasonable
one what the [ __ ] robin says rudy
flipped
i i don't have any confirmation of that
robin but i i don't think that's far off
like why why would why would trump
refuse to pay him if he didn't flip
that's what i think
[Laughter]
old russian tools i like this meme
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
and democrats are the social socialists
commies
they're the ones that love putin and
russia putin's puppies hill reporter
reports even rudy giuliani told trump
his election interference was going too
far
rudy giuliani said you're going too far
the guy who had [ __ ] dripping from his
head
he farted on jenna ellis
in public
trying to defend the big lie
that guy
that guy uh nope grandpa poopy pants
just too far grandpa farty mcsharty is
what i call him i don't know if you guys
have you guys seen my rudy giuliani
videos
i call him grandpa farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani
and it's because of that jenna ellis
that when he when he cropped us to jenna
ellis and that hearing that's that's
where i came up with the farty mchardy
right when he farted on him farted on
him
uh minus lisa says rudy flipped i don't
know i don't know it's hard to tell at
this point who's flipping
i mean everyone has questions about mark
meadows right
it was over a month ago you know you
know
you you got it you got to be careful who
you listen to on twitter
right i get a lot of this [ __ ] from
people i know
they're like oh the doj they're not
doing anything
nothing's happening i'm like what the
[ __ ]
what are you talking about
there's over there's almost 700 and
[ __ ] 50 goddamn charges
that have been charged on
insurrectionists including 11 of them
with conspiracy to commit sedition
and you don't think they're working
their way up the [ __ ] food chain
come on get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] everyone has been wondering
for a whole year why matt gatz isn't
[ __ ] prosecuted yet well we know why
now because the department of justice
was doing their [ __ ] job without you
knowing it
giving immunity to key witnesses
getting plea deals from other key
witnesses
making sure that joel greenberg was
cooperating the entire time yeah that's
why
they're not gonna tell you what they're
doing or who they're talking to
but you can read between the lines a
little bit
we haven't seen federal indictments with
the ukraine stuff for rudy giuliani
i'm guessing that has something to do
with possibly his big [ __ ] mouth and
federal proffers listen there is no one
there is no one more than rudy giuliani
who understands the power of a federal
proffer and what receipts can bring you
in a federal court when you're sitting
in front of a magistrate about to be
sentenced to a [ __ ] federal prison
sentence
rudy giuliani understands this he was a
united states attorney in the southern
district of new york
he knows this
he knows
he knows what receipts can gain you
and if there's anyone that has the
receipts on donald trump it might be
rudy giuliani i'm just saying
snowballing i don't know i don't know
we'll find out
scott says i guess rudy giuliani doesn't
like our new podcast episode with leb
barnes
i blocked he blocked scott
you guys know that leb parnez is
one of the fall guys in the in the
ukraine deal
so hmm
i wonder i wonder if rudy giuliani is
using receipts from ukraine because you
know rudy giuliani is just not facing
prosecution probably from january 6 but
also the ukraine
okay let's continue on this rudy this
this rethread we gotta have some good
means and stuff in here oh there we are
let's see
duty to warn says three times trump
tried to seize the voting machines he
tried their doj which bill barr told him
go [ __ ] himself he tried through the
military and homeland security but why
why root what the [ __ ] i guess rudy was
the only one left that would play ball
you have bill bar and rudy giuliani to
thank for refusing him terrifying that
they were the
free safeties for democracy that is
[ __ ] crazy
if you think about it
and [ __ ] fascist bill barr right
that fascist bill barr
like if if if dick cheney is darth vader
bill barr is like
darth vlob right
think about that for a second
i'm dead serious
look
you guys remember on january 6
when there was only one sitting member
of the house that went to the floor to
stand in solidarity with nancy pelosi
for the violence that had happened the
the attempt of the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup the overthrowing of our government
the treasonous insurrection that
happened
you guys remember who was standing with
liz cheney
do you remember
do you have any idea how significant
that is it doesn't seem like it like in
our world it doesn't seem like that is
significant
dick cheney darth vader
got on a [ __ ] plane
and flew all the way to washington to
stand with nancy pelosi in the house
chamber in solidarity with her
and it wasn't to show the country
it was to send a message to donald trump
hey [ __ ]
i know what liz cheney knows and i'm
saying you're [ __ ] done
why do you think the motherfucker's
terrified and he's on stage at a [ __ ]
nazi rally calling for his people to
commit violence and he'll pardon them if
they do
that's what he's saying that's what the
[ __ ] he's saying
now he's he used all the january six
they're such great they're such great
people and and all that [ __ ] and i
they're being so mistreated their
political prisoners you know they want
to matt gatz marjorie taylor greene
madison cawthorne mo brooks paul gozar
donald trump donald trump jr all these
[ __ ]
all these [ __ ] want to call these these
insurrectionists these treasonous
seditious [ __ ] they want to call them
political prisoners and the reason why
is because they're going to be in the
situation that they're in soon
there are going to be handfuls of these
people who are wrapped up in this
seditious conspiracy
and if you don't think that pardons were
promised donald trump went on stage and
said it
it's always projection with this
[ __ ] we listened for [ __ ]
years no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion no obstruction
no collusion no obstruction no illusion
no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion
i'm gonna pardon them i'm going to
pardon them i'm going to pardon them i'm
going to pardon anyone who wants to
commit violence in my name i'll pardon
them oh if you just want to overthrow
the government my name make me dictator
i'll pardon them
he promised
he promised through members of congress
we've already seen the reporting
he promised members of congress to tell
the people that we're going to commit
violent acts on that day to overthrow
the government of the united states
seditious treason
that he would pardon them if he became
the king
of course he would why wouldn't he he
would be a dictator at that point
he would be a dictator
what would be to stop him
i gave credit there just making sure i
gave credit with reddit we give credit
republicans against trumpism the new
york times is reporting that trump told
rudy giuliani to call dhs to see if they
could take control of the voting
machines
quote unquote
take control
i did a video
and it was it was during that time that
time period where they were talking
about the voting machines they were all
pissed off they wanted to seize the
voting machines mike flynn couldn't stop
talking about it
general traitor mike flynn couldn't stop
[ __ ] talking about those voting
machines
and the reason why is because they were
in the white house
thumping this message to the president
of the united states at the time
who wanted to be dictator and king
kept pounding the message about seizing
the money machines and i made the joke
that mike flynn and sydney powell should
get in their pickup truck and go around
the country and pick all these machines
up because doj told them to go [ __ ]
themselves the dod told them to go [ __ ]
themselves and apparently dhs well rudy
giuliani told trump you're a [ __ ]
crazy lunatic
and that'll definitely send me to prison
that's that's that's that's treason
oh they wanted they wanted him they
wanted violence on january 6 with antifa
and black lives matter so that way
donald trump could could enact the
insurrection act
and they could have martial law
and they could take
control of the government and overthrow
our constitution of the united states
that's why mark milley kept getting in
front of the microphone and telling
members of the military
active or not hey your oath your oath is
to an office to a document not a person
got it it's to the document of the
constitution the united states not
donald trump dumb [ __ ]
okay let's see
uh let's see daily beast reports after
barr shot down the absurd request trump
reportedly had giuliani go to homeland
security to pursue it further
it seems like mr rudy giuliani
some somewhere somewheres
this story is leaking out
maybe at a maybe maybe maybe just maybe
the [ __ ] leaking from from rudy's head
is the truth about who [ __ ] did what
where with the voting machines
george conway says imagine being in the
room let alone
[Music]
a venerated oval one
in which the voice of reason and
rationale belongs to rudy giuliani jesus
christ how in the [ __ ] did we get in
this spot in history or rudy giuliani
the the the disgraced mayor of of new
york
is the voice of reason good lord
what's nola have to say here
uh if you don't think
rock and bonky knew about
about
rudy's calling up d.o dhs
sees voting machines to overturn
elections you don't know how trump land
works subpoena kush
so uh no one's uh
ivanka vonkey is he vunky and jared
let's um we'll retweet uh noel here you
guys want to watch noel's car rant i'm
interested here i haven't seen this one
yet
let's see what he says about vunky
welcome to the car rant you guys like um
noel's car ants let's listen here
hey guys how you doing welcome to the
car rant let's get into it i got some
shadows going on today but let's talk
about jared and ivanka okay we know that
ivanka's been subpoenaed we know that
she demured invonkey speak you know via
publicity statement you know from a pr
person you know spokesperson saying
she's already said what she had to say
and here's ivanka's deal she was the one
giving information to the washington
post and some books that came out about
her role in january 6 as sort of a
peacemaker right there was an obviously
planted quote about how when when pence
was being attacked in one of the
meetings
ivanka said he's a good man i won't
stand for that you know that's [ __ ]
that's not who ivanka is she'd be like
string him up by the [ __ ] balls if it
helps me keep power okay but she was
planting these you know these sort of pr
nuggets out there trying to get ahead of
the inevitable and now she knows that
they want to talk to her her and of
course they want to talk to her right in
that same reporting it showed that she
showed up at the rally you know january
6 that morning and it was odd to the
other staffers because they were like
you haven't been at an event in six
months like what are you doing here you
know we haven't seen you since november
now a sudden you're here this morning
that's because she knew what was up she
knew the plan that had been circulating
amongst their confidants and that
basically her husband was probably
signing off on so she wanted to see how
it went down you know she wanted an
alibi and she wanted to be a witness to
it and she wanted to sort of like
start to insert herself in the narrative
of escaping it right and that's why she
was she was sort of straddling you know
serving two masters because when they
asked her you know mark you know when
they were texting mark meadows and
somebody got in touch with ivanka and
said tell your dad to call it off
like she didn't right she just had some
other lame ass tweet calling them
patriots right but she didn't want to
piss off her dad she wanted to see if it
was still going to work out and but she
also wanted to give herself a back door
in terms of like if history's written
and this goes south i want them to know
that i was a peacemaker she wasn't a
peacemaker she's ruthless and ambitious
just like her father as is jared and you
need to haul them both in you need to
televise it so the world can see what
this family is like and how they work in
concert to corrupt democracy for their
own
and uh knowles right here that ivanka is
that's exactly what she was doing
exactly what um the trumps do that's
what donald trump does he straddles
defense with every single [ __ ] issue
that way you can say oh no i was for it
and against it at the same time at the
same exact time i was just joking oh
well you can't take me literally you
have to take me seriously well you can't
take me seriously you have to take me
literally because i was just joking
that kind of [ __ ]
they know how to do this they know this
game he's right
he's correct thank you noel
let's see what else we got here
anything else i like the rudy giuliani
threads the grandpa farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani okay let's go let's go back to
the trendy trends and the tweety tweets
we're
17 minutes into the second hour
see yesterday we didn't have a lot of
shitless roundup we kind of did a
abbreviated there at the end me and gabe
did
you know just go through the trends to
see what was trending
but we didn't actually get to make make
uh make make much much headway on it so
today we're gonna do two full hours
let's see what else is there anything
else new that is trending of course we
got you know
wayne gretzky's trending jesus christ
people
jesus [ __ ] christ wayne gretzky is
trending because
because he's the greatest hockey player
of all time in his retirement and
tom brady jesus [ __ ] christ people
now you guys seen a whoopi goldberg
uh may it may have made some missteps
and statements
um about the holocaust um
the you know the difference
is i i believe that whoopi goldberg
is very genuine in her apology now the
right is attacking her and some on the
left is attacking her for for her views
here
um i didn't actually watch the clip if
you guys want we can watch the clip here
um it is it is uh unfortunate that she
made these statements i read the
statements and the reason why is because
you know a lot of times we step in it
and we we project the right message the
message that they want
am i a trump spy oh here
someone says i'm a i'm a trump spy yeah
that's exactly what i am as a trump okay
because i wear a red hat and i got a
beard and i'm a white dude you know okay
you don't you need to continue to watch
so uh profence keep watching the show
you'll find out okay let's let's listen
to this clip well also if you're going
to do this then let's be truthful about
it because the holocaust isn't about
race
easy whoopi it was about race now
um i i think i think whoopi goldberg
knows that she stepped in in here um she
has made her apology i i don't i don't
know
oh i see profence i am sorry i am sorry
profence
i thought you were talking to me you're
talking to someone in the chat
i see i apologize
uh you have to forgive me sometimes i'm
trying to do 30 things at once here so
profence i i apologize see this is how
it works whoopi goldberg makes a mistake
and she apologizes for her mistake i
make a mistake and i apologize to pro
fence
i i really do apologize i hope pro fence
is still here if you're still here
profence i apologize you're talking to
some this this this weirdo in the chat
that's got some kind of i don't know
what they're typing in
oh my show yesterday was excellent thank
you very much angela i appreciate it i
appreciate it um i really do
so profess see see this is what happens
this is what happens when you're a
decent human being is when you make a
mistake you apologize for it
once you know you've made the mistake
and whoopi
made some mistakes
but it's it's not about race yes it's
not about right
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man
that's what it's about i mean it's about
that too but it was about a race of
people the jews
being demonized because of their race
and their ethnics and ethnicity
spreading propaganda that their
communists and they were going to
destroy the world
they were the others
not just in germany but also in other
fascist countries
like italy
but it's about white supremacy
but it's not it's not about ideology
but these are two white groups of people
without a weapon
but you're missing the point you're
missing the point the minute you turn it
into race it goes down this alley let's
talk about it for what it is it's how
people treat each other
it's
it is both
it is both but it is about race 100
it was about
is about white supremacists
exterminating a race of people
and whoopi apologized um i'll go let's
um
let's retweet this so you can see
the actual video
here and then we will go back here
and we will read uh
here it is whoopi goldberg this is a
this is her apology
on today's show i said the holocaust is
not about race but about man's humanity
to man
i should have said it was about both
she's right in this statement it is
about both
as greenblatt from the anti-definition
league shared the holocaust was about
the nazi systematically
the systematic annihilation of the
jewish people
who they deemed to be an inferior race i
stand corrected
uh whoopi whoopi
walks back her statements here
the jewish people around the world have
always had my support and that will
never waver i'm sorry for the hurt that
i've caused written with my sincerest
apologies whoopi goldberg
so she understood what what what she did
and the words that she used were a
misstep
not only that
it was
false wrong it is about race
it is about race
and i love how
i love how whoopi goldberg makes these
statements
and the right says you're racist
you're racist whoopi
like what
what do you mean she's a racist if she's
a racist then you [ __ ] sure as hell
are
and then the other thing is dude like ah
cancel cancel her anti-cancer culture
want to cancel whoopi goldberg
because she stepped in a statement
she stepped in a statement
which she apologized for
i don't know i i think i think whoopi
goldberg is a sincere individual
i don't doubt that whoopi goldberg is a
sincere uh empathetic individual i don't
sense that about whoopi colberg
she's a serious person even though she's
a comedian most comedians are very
serious [ __ ] people
it's the people who think they're
comedians who aren't that aren't serious
[ __ ] people
so
i i definitely disagree with whoopi's
original statement
but i'm glad that whoopi
uh
made the apology that she made
and hopefully she'll continue to talk
about this issue on her platform about
the mistake that she made and why she
made it
that's what you have to do
robin says she also talked about it with
stephen colbert last night
now pro fence supplies you got it dude
we're saying the truth and the way
nobody else love your show i was the
first responder at the trade center
so you'd have to go a long way to hurt
my feelings well thank you very much bro
fence supply
we're glad to have you here
and we're glad you love the show keep
continuing to watch
and
sniff out those trump spies for me in
the comments and i'll try not to
disparage you i'll try to i'll try to
recognize that you're talking to them
not me
oh
okay let's see what else do we have here
uh today's taco tuesday that's trending
jesus
oh man
this is the same [ __ ] of the the [ __ ]
tom brady stuff i'm not saying it's not
important to tom brady's retiring people
i'm not saying that
what i'm saying is is you're not gonna
have to worry about a [ __ ] super bowl
that's all i'm saying football you like
football fine great but football is
fantastic
you want football you want to argue
about football you want to you want to
[ __ ] go back and forth to the friends
of which football team's better which
quarterback is better in history
they're they're burning [ __ ] books
they're banning
they're banning to kill a mockingbird
from being taught to children because it
has the n word in it
not them
well they say
they're [ __ ] lying that they want to
ban the book because it has the n word
in it they want to ban the book because
the message that it sends about that
word
this is the crt [ __ ] voodoo
they're trying to use fascism and fear
to ban anti-fascist books
anti-fascist books are going to have the
n word in it they're going to
we've seen this for years with the
adventures of huckleberry friend
the book written
by mark twain
the adventures of huckleberry finn
has the n word in it a lot
but the point of the book
the actual point of the book if you
[ __ ] open it up and read it if you
[ __ ] read the book which is the thing
that that's maybe the problem that we
don't do in this country anymore is you
know actually
bathe in the context of what we're
talking about
we get too lost in the [ __ ] details
about how many times the n word appears
in this book well there's a reason why
that [ __ ] word appears in that book
there's a reason
and to kill a mockingbird to have to
have to kill a mockingbird not be taught
to the american people
and and children not being able to read
to kill a mockingbird is depriving them
depriving them of empathy
to all walks of people
and that's what we're missing
that's why we're so so [ __ ]
hypnotized by tom brady retiring
i mean jesus christ look at this goat is
trending number seven
goat is trending number seven
tom brady's still number two new
england's number three
we need to start getting obsessed with
[ __ ] that matters
that's all i'm saying
or you're not gonna have [ __ ] gretzky
and and and and new england and tom
brady
the nfl the super bowl none of that [ __ ]
is gonna be possible in a fascist state
oh listen listen to me the fascists will
make sure that all the black men that
play in the nfl won't exist
the nazis in orlando that death santas
wouldn't decry
want to make sure
that black men who play in the nfl don't
exist
got it
and there's no safe harbor from this
if they take our [ __ ] democracy away
from us
we are the most powerful country and the
most powerful military that the world
has ever seen
and these fascists want their hands on
it
do you think there's going to be a safe
harbor
for people of other religion you think
there's going to be a safe harbor of
people of other race
and you're complaining are cheering that
tom brady is retiring from the nfl
we are way too comfortable
way
way
way too [ __ ] comfortable
with the entitlements that we have in
this country
and if you're scared then i'm saying you
need to get uncomfortable you're going
to be really [ __ ] uncomfortable if
you don't stay pissed and go [ __ ]
vote and have some strategic [ __ ]
outrage towards this
there won't be an mba
there won't be an nfl there won't be
colleges you like college football you
like college back you want to have march
madness march madness is coming up soon
it won't exist
they want to destroy it all
all of it
that's their plan
the let's go brandon nazis are at the
front door
and they're wanting to come in
and if we don't let them in the front
door they're definitely going to go
through the back door they'll break in
the back door they'll do it
they're planning it right out in the
open on steve bannon's trader tv these
let's go brandon nazis
marjorie taylor greene
matt gatz joe kent they're all running
around the [ __ ] country everywhere
these are [ __ ] these are congress
people who have districts in states and
they're going state to state
having nazi america first rallies
similar to the one that the president
united the former president united
states had donald trump had a nazi rally
in texas
saying i'll pardon you if you commit
violence
jesus christ the entire america first
[ __ ] rallies now that the nazi
rallies that that that matt gatz
marjorie taylor greene matt madness and
cawthorne are holding
is to talk about how the prisoners in in
that are held in detention because
they're charged in the january 6th
violent insurrection the seditious trees
in this act of the cheeto dust kangaroo
attempt
that they're political prisoners
the entire stick the whole thing
they're at the front door
we have to confront them
stay right here we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual partying is not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 pm eastern 3 p.m central watch live on
youtube on twitter and twitch download
on apple and spotify now here's tony
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging in on a break here
i needed a few minutes you know you
gotta have a few minutes every one
through all right okay a guy can take a
break
um
we'll be doing more and more commercials
um you know the breaks and what i mean
by that is gabe gabe you guys you guys
love the the parody commercials um we've
got more in the works he's got more
planned um so we're getting i love the
pardon blanket one though wasn't that
the perfect one for the rant that i just
did about the pardons trying to pardon
these people these [ __ ] fascist
these [ __ ] let's go brandon nazis
um so so be be looking for more of the
parody commercials um as we as we go on
here again you can find us every single
day every single weekday youtube twitter
twitch
noon eastern 11 central make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss anything
because not only do we post the show
over there we also clip stuff up it
might be worth re-watching
uh like the the conversation that we had
yesterday with rachel bitkoffer and and
the conversation we had with the former
guy
yesterday i don't know if you guys
caught that we try to make you guys
laugh here on the tony michaels podcast
you know we figure we figure truth and
laughter
is the best is the best weapons against
fascism
i i think it is i think it is i think i
think democracy is going to reign
through here but we have to we have to
stay pissed we have to go [ __ ] vote
because the only party in this country
that's going to deliver us democracy is
the democrats i mean you know it's a sad
situation
that the republican party has completely
seized their entire party to the let's
go brandon nazis but they have
they want violence they want they want
to race war
and it's very very very very clear that
that's what they want um
here you have
29 ted cruz robin you were talking about
ted cruz's little uh
little supreme court case but here he is
trending because he's he's disparaging
black women
that's what this is
they're disparaging black women in this
country saying oh you can't nominate
someone who's not quite why in the [ __ ]
why in the [ __ ] there's a there's a
[ __ ] long ass list a long ass [ __ ]
list
of black women that are way more [ __ ]
qualified than any white [ __ ] sweaty
old ball sack
for the supreme court frankly i i
wouldn't be opposed
to two three four five supreme court
justices being black women
at this point
women are going to be the only thing
that cleans up this [ __ ] country
after these white [ __ ] men have
destroyed it absolutely [ __ ]
destroyed it it's been long enough
it's been long enough you i'm one of
them i hang around them i know who they
are
they [ __ ] up everything the whole [ __ ]
caboodle
it's time that women
and black women
start to clean up this [ __ ] mess that
men have made
what the [ __ ] why why
why is it when joe biden says you know
what i want to make the court
look like the country like that makes
sense right like the country looks a
certain way there's a certain diversity
in the country
a certain certain way that it looks so
that people understand that the court
will understand them
right
a little
eight nine year old girl
who is black
who sees that there is a black woman on
the supreme court
maybe just maybe understands that
there's someone there that understands
who she is as an american
why don't you [ __ ] get this it's
really it is not complicated it's not
about race that's not what it's about i
mean it is to you because you're a
[ __ ] racist
like if you're worried that joe biden's
gonna nominate a black woman
that he promised for the diversity of
the court because there's never been a
black woman
on the supreme court you understand this
right you get why he said that
you understand why joe biden said he's
gonna put a black woman on the court
because there are there are [ __ ] i
mean
piles and mounds of list of black women
who are completely qualified to serve on
the court
all over this country
not just in federal districts state
districts state houses
political positions
a black women that are way more [ __ ]
qualified than brett kavanaugh could
ever dream of being that [ __ ] [ __ ]
crying into his beer
way more qualified to help america make
the decisions they need to make for the
constitution equality and equity in this
country way way more black women
way way way more qualified than gorsuch
kavanaugh or barrett
[ __ ] them
so i say i say with joe if it were me if
i was advising joe biden like right now
like mr president i don't think you
should nominate
a black woman as the supreme court
justice what i think you should do is
expand the court and nominate three of
them possibly four of them that's what i
would advise you to do
you really want to piss in these
[ __ ] cheerios let's do that
you really want to bring equity and
equality this country you really want
the court to look like the country you
really want the court to be empathetic
to the country's views
and where they're at in american history
nominate
expand the court and nominate four black
women to the court that's what i would
say
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] ted cruz is
insulted
let's read chris's
tweet here ted cruz is insulted by
biden's pledge to nominate a black woman
to the supreme court get the [ __ ] out of
here
had biden just called ted's wife ugly or
claimed his dad assassinated kennedy
ted would be his best buddy
good point chris
it's all [ __ ]
okay
it's called fake strategic outrage right
we've been talking about strategic
outrage
on this show a lot a lot a lot and we're
going to continue to talk about that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this is what they do
this is what they do
it's fake strategic outrage we can have
real strategic outreach like we can be
we can be strategically outraged about
real [ __ ] [ __ ]
right inequality inequity
uh
shitty education
shitty wages
shitty [ __ ] health care the ability
to go bankrupt because you got a medical
bill
not being able to educate your kids from
the age of three till 21
so that they're ready for the new
american economy
economic issues
like inflation protection in the form of
a child tax credit
you want to talk about you want to talk
about insulting
you want to talk about insulting that a
black woman
can't serve on the court
even after joe biden explained to the
american people why he was gonna do it
and then they voted for him to do it get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
again
if i was advising joe biden if it were
me
i would tell him
don't nominate one black woman to the
supreme court let's expand that
[ __ ]
and nominate three or four of them
hell to the yeah
i don't know if you've met a tenacious
black woman
but she would [ __ ] fix this country
quick fast in a goddamn hurry it's about
time we let women run this [ __ ]
so they can fix what us men have
destroyed
amy lynn says good morning to everyone
who knows ted cruz racist with a dead
raccoon for a beard he really does need
to fix that the racism part horrible he
really doesn't need to fix the beard ted
it's really not that hard
i know you can just search on youtube
and it would be really really [ __ ]
easy to fix the beard it really wouldn't
be hard to figure out how to trim that
[ __ ] up it really wouldn't
uh barbara says ted cruz is an
incredible [ __ ]
he's an [ __ ]
he is an [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] him what's joe say here
trump called ted cruz a serial killer he
called his dad a murder and his wife
ugly
what did reek do
he got down on his hands and knees and
kissed the ring ted's a gutless craven
coward who oozes weakness
so i don't give a [ __ ]
about what he thinks about biden's potus
scotus pick yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him
you know that's why [ __ ] em work so well
i think
you know it's such an easy way
easy protest word to make sure people
understand what you're talking about
okay
um so ted cruz
oh
doesn't understand
what we're talking about here let's see
most americans
don't know
that february first first is the
anniversary of the 13th amendment
and also they don't know where is this
[ __ ] thread
where did it go
hmm
well i'm just gonna have to do it myself
see this is the [ __ ] i'm talking about
carter g woodson carter g woodson um for
those of you who don't know let's go to
a post here where
smithsonian
dr carter g woodson known as the father
of black history started the first negro
history week in 1926 to ensure students
would learn black history american
history smithsonian american history
it grew to black history month starting
in 1978.
this is a picture
of dr carter woodson
the father of black history month
black history is american history
why do you think they're so [ __ ]
pissed off that joe biden's gonna going
to nominate a black woman to scotus
why do you think they're so pissed off
hmm i wonder what it could be
i wonder what it could be
and they're calling him bomb threats so
go read some history
on um
dr carter g woodson
the father
of black history month and read why it's
black history month why
go read why
it's american history that's why dumb
[ __ ]
uh tom cotton is trending now because
he's probably a piece of [ __ ]
uh let's see what else do we have in the
trendy trends here let's refresh
the news moves fast and we are on here
for two hours
of course we still have dumb [ __ ] at the
top
[Music]
um uh
black owned um i i think this is uh
trending because people are wanting to
um
and um
uh
black history month you want to
celebrate by
um patronizing black owned businesses
colbert is trending is this because uh
whoopi was on his show is that what's
going on here
um was it robin did you say um
that whoopi was on
his show is that
is that maybe what the
i don't know
someone said something about colbert
whoopi is or is she going on his show
oh it looks like he was she was on the
show
you're correct let's see if we can find
a clip of that real quick
of course they'll probably ding me on it
they'll be like no copyright copyright
it doesn't look like it's up anywhere
maybe they didn't post it
see this is the trouble sometimes
you can't find oh here it is maybe
yeah [ __ ] that guy i'm not gonna put him
[Music]
okay well
i'm gonna i'm not gonna play the clip
because they're going to ding me
what they'll do is they'll silence it so
on when that replay you won't even be
able to hear the son of a [ __ ]
dmca
they're getting they're cracking down on
that [ __ ] everywhere
okay let's see
we are 45 minutes into the hour
well madison catherine's trending
what's going on here
is there a madison cothron clip please
tell me there's a clip of him being
really [ __ ] dumb
oh yep here ron's got it
uh madison gotham trump has become like
a father to me
i get to talk to him just about every
single day he's incredible such a genius
i mean compared to madison cawthorne
that might be true
[Music]
ah it's [ __ ] real let's let's listen
to this idiot a rapid fire around really
simple questions now i know you already
expressed
daily caller
right there right there daily caller
that's your support for both trump and
desantis but what is the first word that
comes to mind when i say trumper
desantis
trump
okay
trump's become like a father to me i get
to talk to him just about every single
day he's incredible he's such a genius
especially when i'm trying to jesus
christ because you know being 26 years
old obviously i don't have a ridiculous
amount of
experience with dealing with foreign
policy yet but so if then if i can just
call the president yeah we know we know
you don't have any experience dealing
with anybody's dumb [ __ ] tell me
exactly what what the whole background
is to it so oh i'm sure donald trump is
just dying to tell you the whole
background on everything
and i'm sure he'll tell you about you
know the planes that they had during the
revolutionary war get the [ __ ] out of
here
hitler i didn't call him hitler i didn't
call him sittlers other people call him
that
call him sittler they call him settler
not me
um
let's see here here's um
a video
with steve schmidt
madison cawthorne before and after
january 6th i'm just going to put some
of what he said call your congressman
you can lightly threaten them the future
of republic of the republic hinges on
the actions of a solitary few it's time
to fight that's january 4th august 29
2021 he referred to insurrection
defendants as political prisoners spoke
of going to bust them out
that same day he also added if our
election systems continue to be rigged
it's going to lead to one place and
that's bloodshed his lawyer is now using
citing the confederate amnesty act to
defend him his lawyer talks about this
1872 amnesty act which removed all
persons whatsoever from the disability
under section 3 as a result in engaging
instructions using the confederate
defense your
thoughts um
his statements speak for themselves troy
he is engaged in what will in the end be
a wide-ranging conspiracy to overthrow
the legitimately and democratically
elected government of the united states
that's what this is all about now with
madison kawhorn putting aside for a
moment that he is a political extremist
and has proven that many times over and
over
this is a character like the talented mr
ripley
everything about this person and i mean
everything the details of his accident
his supposed admission and denial into
annapolis
every assertion of fact that he has ever
made about himself and who he is
is false
he is like an imposter character from a
movie
and he is a member of congress
in his mid-20s
who is constantly
inciting violence on one social media
platform or another so this lawsuit is
meritorious
it's appropriate
and he is just one
of a number of members of congress that
by the time this is all over
um
will be clearly implicated in this
conspiracy
um not by the things
that we don't already know
um
but powerfully by their own words
over this last year so
so
look
he he is what he appears to be a a young
fascist uh who detests american
democracy political extremist who yearns
and thirsts for political violence to
break out uh he is appalling
the reason why the reason why um
mj says here
i hate that corn i hate that corn so
goddamn much uh professors this is a
good one i think you're talking about
this clip uh
also cauthern only
seems to care about inciting violence
well the reason why it seems like
madison catherine only cares about
inciting violence is because he's
talking to the cheeto dust mobster every
day
we just seen the clip before he said oh
i talk to him every day he's a genius
he's a genius he tells me exactly how to
incite violence and make sure that
fascism is on the rise in this country
how to continue to stoke the fear how to
continue to stoke the violence
that's what he means that's what he
means that's what i'm talking about
these let's go brandon nazis
they're at the front door fascism's here
it's here
and we have to stay pissed we have to go
[ __ ] vote
because democrats are the only one that
are going to deliver us democracy
in our modern history today republicans
want to destroy democracy they want a
fascist state and you want the super
bowl you want to decide what pizza what
chips you're going to have on the day of
the super bowl you want to watch your
favorite players play the game
you want march madness do you like
college basketball
well you might have to start paying
attention
to all the [ __ ] that matters
otherwise we won't have those things
fascism doesn't allow it
they will destroy
everything in its path
go look at the history
we'll be putting up bonehead of the week
poll today go follow at tony michael's
pod for the bonehead of the week poll
remember we do that every week and then
we do the bonehead of the week every
friday so we'll be doing that in the
second hour this week but remember we
have a very [ __ ] special interview
really good one
coming it's gonna it might even make
news i don't know maybe to make news i
don't know
it's very big it's related to the
january 6 insurrectionist
i can't wait to air it we'll be teasing
it either tomorrow or thursday i'm
hoping to air it thursday or friday uh
we're working on getting it cut and
getting it ready to air so pay attention
to that watch the twitter feed again
follow the tony michael spot follow me
the tony michaels and follow gabe at i
am gabe sanchez
and also subscribe to the youtube
channel you are not going to want to
miss
you are not going to want to miss the
interview that we have trust me on this
and we will be airing it live
and i'll be we'll be announcing that
when we do air it live
and remember we're on every single
weekday now two hours noon eastern 11th
central
right here on youtube and twitter and
twitch
so until tomorrow at noon eastern
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking